.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Ich habe 2 Std. lang gezittert.
Vor Kälte oder wegen der Nerven.
Verstehen Sie?
Hier war die Küche.
Es war mal eine Dreizimmerwohnung.
Ich bin während Monaten in
der Ukraine unterwegs, bei Menschen,
die im russischen Angriffskrieg
alles verloren haben.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Als wir ankamen, haben wir gesehen,
wie Männer die Leute ausgruben und
sie hier auf den Vorplatz legten.
Die Körper waren nicht mehr ganz,
sondern in Stücken:
Knochen, Hände, Füsse.
Ein Jahr Krieg -
kein Tag ohne Luftalarm,
kein Tag ohne russischen
Beschuss auf die Ukraine.
Offiziell bestätigt
sind über 9'000 getötete Zivilisten,
darunter 495 Kinder.
Wie viele Zivilisten
die russische Armee in der Ukraine
genau getötet hat, weiss niemand.
Zerstörung ist nach einem Jahr Krieg
in vielen Städten der Ukraine
anzutreffen.
Auch Häuser wie dieses:
einst ein Wohnhaus, jetzt eine Ruine.
Auf dieses Haus
an der Perwomajskaja-Strasse Nummer 2
stosse ich
ein halbes Jahr nach Kriegsbeginn -
im September 2022 in Isjum.
Die Stadt Isjum
liegt in der Ostukraine.
Isjum
stand während Monaten unter Beschuss
und gehört zu den am stärksten vom
Krieg zerstörten Städten des Landes.
In der Ostukraine
ist die Front nicht weit.
Die Bedrohung ist hier
immer noch allgegenwärtig.
Es ist ein warmer Tag im Herbst,
als ich dem Haus
zum ersten Mal begegne.
Trümmer und Sonnenschein -
nichts will zusammenpassen.
Ich beginne
mit der Suche nach Überlebenden,
die mir erzählen können,
was hier vorgefallen ist.
Wir treffen einen Überlebenden, der
jahrelang in diesem Haus gelebt hat:
Michail Jazentjuk.
Um 9 Uhr sagte meine Enkelin zu mir:
"Opa, bring mir einen Tee."
Ich nahm die Thermosflasche, den Tee
und ging zur Treppe.
Meine Frau sagte noch:
"Mischa, ich komme mit."
Ich sagte:
"Zieh dich an, ich warte."
Bevor sie bei mir auf dem Flur war,
gab es diese Explosion.
Wie lange ich ohne Bewusstsein war,
weiss ich nicht.
Als ich zu mir kam,
verstand ich, dass ich allein war.
Ich rief: "Natascha! Olja! Witali!"
Nirgendwo waren Geräusche zu hören.
So begann ich nach Hilfe zu rufen.
Er hat als Einziger seiner Familie
den Angriff vor Ort überlebt.
Insgesamt starben
sechs Mitglieder seiner Familie:
seine Frau,
seine Tochter, sein Schwiegersohn ...
... und drei seiner Enkelkinder.
* Düstere Musik *
Ich war dort,
hier bei diesem Eingang.
Dort lag ich weiter unten.
Alle anderen Leute waren hier.
Hier, in diesem Bereich.
Es wurden Leute hier gefunden ...
... und hier.
Die Mehrheit der Verstorbenen
wurde hier gefunden.
Dieses Video
wurde Anfang März aufgenommen,
nur wenige Tage bevor die
russische Armee das Haus zerstörte.
Die Frau, die das Video gemacht hat,
wurde bei der Explosion getötet.
Die Menschen suchten im Keller Schutz
und wurden von Trümmern begraben.
Wie viele getötet wurden ist unklar.
Offiziell bestätigt sind 44 Tote.
Augenzeugen der Ausgrabung
sprechen von 54 Opfern.
Die Bewohner des Hauses
hatten einen gemeinsamen Chat.
Die letzten Nachrichten
stammen von Anfang März.
Hier hat ein Nachbar, der auch
getötet wurde, noch geschrieben:
"Im Falle eines Beschusses:
Schalten Sie alle das Gas aus!"
"Es heisst, Panzer würden
in unsere Richtung fahren -
nicht unsere Panzer."
Damals durfte man das Licht
nicht mehr anschalten,
damit um Himmels willen
nichts passieren würde.
Alle Vorsichtsmassnahmen
halfen nichts.
Am 9. März, kurz nach 9 Uhr,
sollte sich das Leben der Bewohner
des Hauses für immer verändern.
Die Familie von Irina
zog unmittelbar nach Bau des Hauses
in den 1980er-Jahren
ins Haus an der Perwomajskaja -
der Strasse des 1. Mais.
Irina war damals acht Jahre alt.
Ich kann mich noch erinnern,
wie das Haus gebaut wurde.
Mama und Papa gehörten zu den
Leuten, die das Haus gebaut hatten.
So viele Jahre
haben wir dort gelebt ...
Die Familie hat überlebt,
weil sie wenige Tage
vor der Explosion weggefahren ist.
* Sie spricht ukrainisch. *
Wir sind zwischen dem 4. und 5. März
weggefahren.
In Isjum gab es zu diesem Zeitpunkt
bereits kein fliessendes Wasser
und keinen Strom mehr.
Meine Mutter ist gehbehindert.
Sie fragte: "Wohin sollen wir?"
Ich sagte: "Lass uns zu Grossmutter
auf das Dorf fahren."
"Dort können wir
auf dem Holzherd Wasser kochen."
Ein erstes Mal
nach Isjum zurückgekehrt,
ist Irina erst einen Monat nach
dem Tod ihrer Nachbarn und Freunde.
Wir fahren mit ihr
zurück in die Stadt.
Jede Rückkehr ist eine Rückkehr
in eine verlorene Vergangenheit
voller Erinnerungen.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Eine Freundin rief mich noch an:
"Komm in den Keller runter."
Sie bot mir an, mit dem Kinderwagen
für meine Tochter zu helfen.
Aber ich sagte: "Nein,
in den Keller komme ich nicht."
Ich ging fast nie in den Keller.
Ich hatte immer Angst,
dort hinabzusteigen.
Ich hatte Angst, das Haus
könnte über mir zusammenbrechen.
Es gibt nur wenige Waffen,
die ein fünfstöckiges Haus
zum Einsturz bringen können.
150'000 Häuser sind laut Schätzungen
der ukrainischen Behörden
von der russischen Armee
im Krieg bisher zerstört worden.
Beim Haus an der Perwomajskaja gehen
die ukrainischen Behörden davon aus,
dass Russlands Armee eine Flieger-
bombe über dem Haus abgeworfen hat.
Dabei soll es sich um eine
FAB-500-Fliegerbombe gehandelt haben.
Hier Bilder vom russischen
Verteidigungsministerium.
Diese Fliegerbomben
wurden von der russischen Armee
bereits in der Vergangenheit
in anderen Kriegen,
wie hier in Syrien, eingesetzt.
Auch zivile Infrastruktur
in der Ukraine
hat die russische Armee nachweislich
mit dieser Fliegerbombe angegriffen.
Z.B. die Stadt Charkiw.
Solche Bomben
gegen zivile Ziele einzusetzen
ist ein Kriegsverbrechen.
Charkiw ist 120 km Luftlinie
von Isjum entfernt.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Auch auf Isjum
sollen mind. zwei FAB-500-
Fliegerbomben abgeworfen worden sein.
Ich habe kein Flugzeug gehört.
Vielleicht weil ich im Keller war.
An den Tagen zuvor
habe ich Explosionen gehört.
Aber am 9. März, da kann ich
mich nicht daran erinnern.
Die Erinnerungen von Michail
sind verschwommen,
teilweise bruchstückhaft.
Er scheint heute überzeugt davon,
dass er sich selbst
aus den Trümmern befreit hat.
Auch wenn andere
dieser Erinnerung widersprechen.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Michail
ist verabredet mit jenem Nachbarn,
der ihn nach der Explosion
unter den Trümmern gefunden hat.
Hallo Sascha.
- Hallo.
Wie geht es dir?
- Gut.
Rasiere dich mal.
- Nein, werde ich nicht.
Hier lag Mischa.
Ich kam, habe versucht,
Mischa aus den Trümmern zu befreien.
Wir haben Ziegelsteine weggeräumt.
Sie
räumten zu zweit Ziegelsteine weg.
Dann fielen Trümmer von oben runter.
Du gingst mit dem anderen weg
in dein Häuschen nebenan.
Warum erzählst du so etwas?
Du weisst doch, wie es war.
Wir räumten Ziegelsteine weg
und du hast geschrien,
wir sollen deine Familie befreien.
Michail fühlt sich alleingelassen
und Oleksander ist verletzt,
dass ihm der Nachbar unterstellt,
ihn zurückgelassen zu haben.
In einem Punkt sind sie sich einig:
Die Verschütteten
aus dem Keller zu befreien
war zu diesem Zeitpunkt unmöglich.
Zu schwer wogen die Betonplatten,
unter welchen
die Menschen begraben waren.
Es sollte
noch mehr als einen Monat vergehen,
bis die Toten aus dem Keller
geborgen werden konnten.
In der Zwischenzeit
versuchten die Überlebenden
aus ihren Wohnungen zu retten,
was zu retten war.
Oleksander nimmt uns mit
in die Ruine seiner Wohnung.
Dazu muss er durch
die zerstörte Wohnung eines Nachbarn,
der beim Angriff getötet wurde.
Oleksander ist das unangenehm.
Verzeihen Sie bitte.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Oh!
Diese Figur aus Thailand
ist am Leben.
Am 8. März war ich in der Wohnung.
Ich habe einen Kaffee getrunken,
mich aufs Sofa gelegt
und eine Sendung auf Youtube
angesehen.
Abends um 21 Uhr ging ich
ins Wochenendhäuschen nebenan.
Als hätte ich gespürt,
dass ich raus muss.
Wäre ich hiergeblieben, würde ich
jetzt auch dort unten liegen.
Laut Schätzungen
der ukrainischen Behörden
lebten Ende des Jahres
2,4 Mio. Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer
in zerstörten
oder schwer beschädigten Wohnungen.
Oleksander bringt die noch erhaltene
Figur seiner Frau Tetjana.
Sie ist schon viele Jahre bei uns.
Was einem gehört, ist einem teuer.
Sie klammern sich an die wenigen
Überbleibsel ihres einstigen Lebens.
Wir sind jetzt ohne Bleibe.
Aber das Schlimmste ist, dass es
unsere Nachbarn nicht mehr gibt.
Wir lebten einst vor uns hin -
Nachbarn sind Nachbarn.
Seit sie tot sind,
fühlen wir uns wie Waisen.
Oleksander und Tetjana leben heute
in ihrem Wochenendhäuschen,
gleich neben dem zerstörten Wohnhaus.
Zusammen mit ihrem Hund.
Als die Flugzeuge flogen,
hatte er Angst.
Auch wir nahmen Beruhigungsmittel.
Er ist nicht erzogen,
weil er im Luftschutzkeller
während des Krieges gross wurde.
Auch in der Nähe
ihres Wochenendhäuschens
haben Raketen eingeschlagen.
Sie haben kein Dach
und heizen mit einem alten Holzofen.
Nachdem
die Fliegerbombe eingeschlagen hat,
fanden mehrere Nachbarn, die gerettet
werden konnten, hier Unterschlupf.
Wir haben
überall Matratzen hingelegt
und uns
mit allem Möglichen zugedeckt.
Wir versuchten zu heizen,
denn es war sehr kalt.
Aber irgendetwas mit dem Ofen
stimmte nicht.
In den vergangenen Monaten
lebten sie hier zu zweit
weiter
unter schwierigsten Bedingungen.
Ich bin ja ein Mann.
Aber wenn ich mit dem Hund rausging,
habe ich jedes Mal geweint.
Jetzt bin ich abgehärtet,
aber es war schwer.
Am allerschwersten war es, als sie
begonnen haben, die Leute zu bergen.
Sie schauen
von ihrer vorübergehenden Bleibe
jeden Tag
auf die Ruinen ihrer alten Wohnung.
Und an jenen Ort, an dem
ihre Nachbarn im Keller starben.
Als die Leute anonym
unter einer Nummer begraben wurden,
liessen die Russen
niemanden zu den Gräbern.
Auch Angehörige nicht.
Vergraben wurden die Getöteten gleich
hinter den Eingangstoren zur Stadt.
Ich bin an diesem Ort -
wenige Tage nach der Befreiung der
Stadt durch die ukrainische Armee.
Während knapp sechs Monaten
hatte die russische Armee
die Stadt besetzt gehalten.
Während der Besatzung
von Ende März bis Mitte September
starben Hunderte Menschen in Isjum.
Mehrere Folterkeller
wurden nach der Befreiung gefunden.
Darüber
will vor Ort niemand sprechen.
Die Menschen hier befürchten,
die russische Armee
könnte jederzeit zurückkommen.
Isjum ist gezeichnet vom Krieg.
Die Strassen
sind voller Militärtechnik,
welche die russische Armee
beim Rückzug zurückgelassen hat.
Erstmals nach Ende der Besatzung
ist auch das Massengrab zugänglich.
Alle Zivilisten, die während
der Besatzung gestorben sind,
wurden hier vergraben.
In 445 Gräbern.
Auch fast alle Getöteten
des Hauses an der Perwomajskaja
sind hier beerdigt.
Die Nachbarn und Freunde
von Irina, Oleksander und Michail.
Ich bin während der Exhumierungen
vor Ort und kämpfe mit Übelkeit.
Geruch und Anblick der verwesenden
Leichen sind nur schwer auszuhalten.
Um die Todesursache und die Identität
feststellen zu können,
werden die Toten exhumiert.
Bislang wurden in der Ukraine
mehr als 1'000 Zivilisten und Sol-
daten aus Massengräbern exhumiert.
Mehrere zehntausend Untersuchungen
haben die ukrainischen Behörden
wegen mutmasslicher russischer
Kriegsverbrechen aufgenommen.
Die exhumierten Leichen
werden in die nächstgelegene
grössere Stadt gefahren.
Bis heute dauern
diese Untersuchungen der Behörden an.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Während der Besatzung hat er
geholfen, die Menschen zu vergraben -
der 30-jährige Pawlo Golub.
Ich hatte nach den Begräbnissen
einen Bandscheibenvorfall,
der sich noch verschlimmert hat.
Es war schmerzhaft.
Wir mussten die Leichen zu zweit,
zu dritt oder zu viert tragen.
Es gab sehr unterschiedliche Leute,
teilweise waren die sehr schwer.
Alle, die sich
an den Begräbnissen beteiligt haben,
trugen
gesundheitliche Schäden davon.
Er nimmt uns mit zu Galina.
Galinas Sohn
lebte im Haus an der Perwomajskaja.
Ihr Sohn und seine Familie
sind beim Angriff getötet worden.
Pawlo will Galina zum Massengrab
am Stadtrand begleiten.
Auch ihre Familie hat Pawlo begraben.
Er hat während der Besatzung erlebt,
wie überall in der Stadt Tote lagen.
Wir gingen durch die Stadt, waren
unterwegs in den Luftschutzkellern.
In jedem Innenhof
standen damals Kreuze von Menschen,
die direkt dort begraben waren.
Die einen waren
eines natürlichen Todes gestorben,
die anderen unter Beschuss.
Einige hielten es schlicht nicht
mehr aus und haben Suizid begangen.
Pawlo meldet sich als Freiwilliger,
um die getöteten Zivilisten
ausserhalb der Stadt zu begraben.
Längst nicht alle
wollten sich darum kümmern.
Ich habe nach dem Prinzip gehandelt:
Wer, wenn nicht wir?
Abzuwarten war keine Option.
Der Sommer stand vor der Tür.
Und es war nicht klar,
wo das alles noch enden würde.
Zwischen April und Mai
fuhr Pawlo hierher,
um Zivilisten zu beerdigen.
Ohne ihn hätte sich Galina
nicht hierher getraut.
Ihre Verwandten hatte sie damals
bereits bei der Bergung aus dem
Keller versucht zu identifizieren.
Es waren zwei Monate vergangen,
bis sie ausgegraben wurden.
Der Gestank war grauenhaft.
Man konnte sie nicht identifizieren.
Sie waren nicht zu erkennen.
Die Kleider, die Gesichter,
die Haare waren verbrannt.
Wo sind unsere Kreuze?
- Dort.
Sie tragen alle Namensschilder.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Ach, so viele wurden hier beerdigt.
Ich habe allen auch Blumen gekauft.
Ich sehe es, danke dir.
Meinen Sohn habe ich erkannt.
Er war der Einzige
mit einem Gesicht.
Nur bei ihm
war das Gesicht erhalten.
Als sie ihn geborgen haben,
zeigte sich, dass sein Kopf
unter Rohren begraben lag.
Die Rohre waren über seinem Kopf
in Stücke geborsten.
Ihn zu erkennen, war leichter.
Er war mit 1,90 m sehr gross
und 105 kg schwer.
Galina konnte ihre Schwiegertochter
und die älteste Enkeltochter
nach der Bergung aus dem Keller
nicht identifizieren.
Sie wartet
seit der Aushebung des Massengrabes
auf die Ergebnisse der DNA-Analysen.
Die leitende Ermittlerin sagte mir,
dass sie sich bei mir melden wird,
sobald die Ergebnisse
der DNA-Analysen vorliegen.
Wenn die da sind,
werde ich meine Angehörigen abholen
und selbst beerdigen.
Ein Familiengrab wird uns
nicht gestattet, aber Einzelgräber.
Ich möchte sie alle beerdigen.
Das Massengrab in Isjum
ist eines von insgesamt 21 bekannten
Massengräbern in der Ukraine.
Alle entstanden in Gebieten,
die vorübergehend
von den Russen besetzt waren.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Die Angehörigen fast ein Jahr
nach ihrem Tod zu beerdigen,
das wünschen sich auch jene,
die fern der Heimat Isjum leben.
Es ist
so ein schwerer Gefühlszustand,
wenn du selbst nicht
auf dem Friedhof weinen kannst,
weil du schon so viel durchlitten
hast, keine Tränen mehr hast.
Gar keine Kraft
für gar nichts mehr bleibt,
um überhaupt noch Emotionen
zu spüren.
Ich treffe die 20-jährige Aljona
in Polen.
Sie lebt seit eineinhalb Jahren hier.
Aljona ist im Haus
an der Perwomajskaja in Isjum
im dritten Stock aufgewachsen.
Hier lebte sie mit ihren Eltern,
bis sie volljährig wurde.
Im Keller des Hauses starben
ihre Eltern und ihre Grossmutter.
Aljona kann nicht nach Isjum fahren,
weil sie sonst ihren Aufenthalts-
status in Polen verlieren würde.
Auf diesem Friedhof, knapp 300 km
westlich der Hauptstadt Warschau,
hat sie einen Ort gefunden,
wo sie sich mit ihren Eltern
verbunden fühlt.
Ich habe Fotos meiner Eltern
mitgebracht,
damit ich sie vor mir sehe.
Damit ich mich
von ihnen verabschieden kann.
Ich bin mit 20 Jahren
Vollwaise geworden.
Ich habe keine Mutter, keinen Vater.
Ich habe eine Unterstützung.
Auf dem Friedhof
hat der lokale Bürgermeister
einen Gedenkstein für die Kriegsopfer
in der Ukraine errichten lassen.
Der Stein steht auf Steinen
und ist umgeben von Leere.
Für mich ist das
wie ein Symbol dessen,
was jetzt vor sich geht in Isjum.
Rundherum wächst noch etwas.
Dort, wo man den Stein hingestellt
hat, ist einfach nichts.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Es gibt nichts,
was Aljona die eigenen Eltern
wieder zurückbringen könnte.
Mir bleibt in dieser Situation
als Journalistin nur etwas:
Menschen wie Aljona zuzuhören
und ihnen eine Stimme zu geben.
Ich kann nicht sagen,
dass unser Leben normal weitergeht.
Nein, alles hat sich verändert.
Ich fühle mich nicht so,
als ob ich 20 wäre.
Ich möchte nicht ausgehen,
so wie andere,
weil mir
meine Familie genommen wurde.
Du wirst mit einem Schlag
30 Jahre älter.
Ein wenig Trost
findet Aljona bei ihrer Katze.
Nach dem Tod ihrer Eltern
war es für Aljona sehr schwer,
in ihrem Leben
wieder Tritt zu fassen.
Ich habe mir
die Haare geschnitten und gefärbt,
weil ich meiner Mutter
immer ähnlicher sehe.
Es ist schwer,
in den Spiegel zu sehen
und meine Mutter
darin wiederzuerkennen.
Ich kann nicht mit ihr sprechen, sie
nicht umarmen, ihr nichts erzählen.
Seit ich meine Haare
geschnitten habe,
fällt mir das Atmen leichter.
Die Vorstellung,
in Zukunft irgendwann einmal
nach Isjum zurückzukehren,
erfüllt sie mit Angst.
Es ist nicht mehr die Stadt,
an welche ich mich erinnere.
Ich möchte dorthin zurückkehren,
aber dies mit eigenen Augen
zu sehen, ist beängstigend.
Früher war es eine sehr schöne Stadt
mit vielen jungen Menschen.
Viele sind weggefahren,
aber immer zurückkehrt.
Es gab immer Leben in der Stadt.
Aber jetzt gibt es das nicht
und wird es auch nicht mehr geben.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Vom Leben an der Perwomajskaja
sind den Bewohnern nur Erinnerungen
und Fotografien geblieben.
Unsere Wohnung war dort oben,
wo das Linoleum runterhängt.
Hier liegen
noch die Bücher meines Sohnes,
die aus der Wohnung
runtergefallen sind.
Diese Schulhefte
aus der fünften Klasse ...
Hier steht noch sein Name:
Andrei Kowalenko.
In ihrer Wohnung ist mehr erhalten
geblieben als in anderen Wohnungen.
Für sie ein schwacher Trost.
Was wir mitnehmen konnten,
haben wir mitgenommen.
Alles können wir
sowieso nicht mitnehmen,
wir leben ja
in einer fremden Wohnung.
Offiziell wurden
4,8 Mio. Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer
innerhalb des Landes
vom Krieg vertrieben.
Über die Landesgrenzen hinaus
sind 4 Mio. Menschen geflüchtet.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Für die Menschen,
die ich in Isjum kennengelernt habe,
hat der Krieg alles verändert.
Pawlo möchte weg.
Zumindest für eine Weile.
Er packt seine Sachen.
Noch immer rufen Leute an und fragen
nach Hilfe, um jemanden zu finden.
Viele Menschen sind verschollen.
Sobald du dich
ein wenig erholen konntest,
ruft wieder jemand an
und alles kommt hoch.
Ich kann nicht sagen, dass ich
psychisch schwer gelitten habe.
Aber ich möchte
ohne solche Ausbrüche leben.
Ich möchte Ruhe, und unter einem
friedlichen Himmel weiterleben.
Unter einem friedlichen Himmel
zu leben ...
... das wünschen sich
auch Oleksander und seine Frau.
Er versucht, das Dach ihrer
temporären Bleibe zu reparieren.
So gut es irgendwie geht.
Niemand hat auf uns gewartet.
Wir können uns
nur auf uns selbst verlassen.
Wir sammeln hier und dort Holz.
So in der Art.
Sie wünschen sich nichts mehr,
als dass ihr altes Leben
zurückkehren würde.
Kinder haben hier Krach gemacht.
Davon hatten wir manchmal genug,
wenn sie im Innenhof bei den Garagen
etwas kaputtgehauen haben
und herumgetollt sind.
Ich habe sie dann angeschrien:
"Ich habe Kopfschmerzen!"
Mein Gott, jetzt denke ich mir:
"Sollen sie doch schreien
und Dinge kaputtschlagen."
"Hauptsache, sie sind am Leben."
Wenn nur alles wieder so wäre,
wie es einmal war.
So eine unheimliche Ruhe.
Mit der unheimlichen Ruhe
nach dem Angriff
müssen sie irgendwie zurechtkommen.
Allen voran Michail, der den
Bombenangriff vor Ort überlebt hat.
Die Strasse Perwomajskaja
wurde in der Zwischenzeit
von den ukrainischen Behörden
im Zuge der Entkommunisierung
des Landes umbenannt
in die Strasse des Gedenkens.
Trotz der Bedrohungslage
in der Ostukraine
ist Michail nach Isjum zurückgekehrt.
Ich bin am 1. Dezember
hierher zurückgekehrt.
Zuvor war ich in der Region
Tscherkassy als Binnenflüchtling.
Dort gibt es
sehr viele Binnenflüchtlinge.
Das Zuhause ist das Zuhause,
die Fremde ist die Fremde.
Seit seiner Rückkehr nach Isjum
arbeitet Michail
in einem Kindergarten als Wachmann.
Es kam so, dass mich der Direktor
des Kindergartens anrief und sagte,
dass sie jemanden suchen, der bei
ihnen als Wachmann arbeiten würde.
Ich bin innerhalb
von zwei Tagen hergefahren.
Meine verstorbene Tochter
hat hier eine Wohnung hinterlassen.
Dort wohne ich jetzt.
Dort gibt es Licht, Wasser und Gas.
Für Michail
ist die Arbeit im Kindergarten
in erster Linie Ablenkung.
Nach Isjum wollte ich zurück,
weil es mein Zuhause ist.
Die Arbeit ist eine Sache.
Wie soll ich Ihnen das sagen?
Ich habe
einfach so lange hier gelebt.
Ich bin zwar nicht hier geboren,
aber ich habe 42 Jahre hier gelebt.
Hier gibt es Arbeit,
hier sind meine Freunde.
Vieles ist hier.
Michail möchte bleiben,
obwohl er beinahe seine ganze Familie
hier verloren hat.
Es ist kurz vor Weihnachten.
Die Kinder der Stadt
bekommen humanitäre Hilfe.
Für ein paar unbeschwerte Momente
für die Kinder
nach Monaten des Krieges
packt Michail an.
Er hilft beim Ausladen und
beim Koordinieren der Hilfsaktion.
Er selbst
steht nur selten eine Minute still.
Auch Galina hat wieder eine Arbeit
als Verkäuferin aufgenommen,
obwohl sie mit ihren 71 Jahren
längst im Pensionsalter wäre.
Ihr bleibt keine andere Wahl
als in Isjum zu bleiben.
Wohin soll ich den fahren?
Ich will nirgendwohin fahren.
Zum Wegfahren
braucht es eine Menge Geld,
damit man ein gutes Leben hat.
Doch die ukrainischen Renten
sind sehr niedrig.
Ich bekomme umgerechnet
gerade einmal 60 Fr. im Monat.
Die einen verlassen Isjum,
die anderen bleiben.
Das Haus wird bald Geschichte sein.
Die Ruinen sollen abgerissen werden.
Ein Haus und seine Bewohner -
ein Schicksal,
das mich nicht mehr losliess.
Eines unter Tausenden in der Ukraine.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023